le top départ de la 4ème édition du
festival leçon continue à peine donné
les premiers festivaliers sont déjà
nombreux à prendre leurs marques dans
les allées ombragées du château d'ars le
marché des luthiers 8 accueille cent
trente neuf professionnels à l'ombre des
arbres vivants
c'est la locomotive de ce rendez vous
mondial des musiciens trad autour duquel
le festival s'est construit et c'est
cette philosophie que les actuels
responsables entendent perpétuer
on souhaite un événement participatif et
cet effort de prix qu'on contribue à ça
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui viennent
qui payent leurs autres hectares et qui
au delà de ça anime nos parcs et anime
des boeufs et propose aux festivaliers
des animations que nous mêmes nous
n'avons pas prévu sur le programme une
heure après l'ouverture
l'une des scènes la pommeraie accueille
son premier cours de danse un parc est
plein attentif à suivre les instructions
ici tout le monde danse à défaut de
jouer d'un instrument c'est pourquoi la
programmation du festival adapter ce
tempo qui correspond à l'esprit de la
musique
la particularité est quand même de la
musique traditionnelle puis c'est quand
même notre truc ici c'est de faire
danser donc on a beaucoup de groupes et
excellent d'excellents groupes mais qui
sont surtout des groupes de balle chaque
soir les concerts feront découvrir des
horizons musicaux très différents
ce soir on commence avec l'iran et la
galice mais les rencontres autour de la
danse et de la musique se poursuivra
ensuite jusqu'au petit matin
l'an passé plus de 14 mille personnes
ont cédé aux charmes du festival